aucune femme ne recourt de gaieté de
coeur à l'avortement
il suffit d'écouter les femmes novembre
simone veil alors ministre de la santé
présente son projet de loi sur
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
deux mois plus tard le 17 janvier 1975
la loi veil dépénalise ivg les femmes
peuvent avorter jusqu'à dix semaines de
grossesse
la loi est promulguée à titre
expérimental reconduite indéfiniment
c'est une avancée majeure de
l'émancipation féminine
mais très vite les femmes enceintes se
heurte à des obstacles notamment celui
du délai le problème c'est le problème
des délais dépassés 10 cm ne sait trop
peu surtout la de la façon dont la loi
est appliquée c'est à dire l'information
n'est pas donnée correctement tard
beaucoup de médecins
face à ces contraintes certaines femmes
sont obligées d'avorter à l'étranger
comme aux pays-bas ou ivg peut se
pratiquer jusqu'à 22 semaines de
grossesse il ya beaucoup de femmes qui
viennent à maastricht et d'autres femmes
qui va en laine ou soixante dix pour
cent des de la population de l'inde sont
des françaises ça fait presque 1500
femmes par an à l'aide seulement en
france se faire avorter relève parfois
du parcours du combattant
face à ce délai de dix semaines des
femmes revendiquent un allongement du
délai de gvg à l'image de la féministe
et philosophe elisabeth badinter en 1999
24 ans après la loi veil
il ya urgence et moi je pense qu'il n'y
a pas de délai nécessaire excusez moi
pour allonger de deux ou trois ou quatre
semaines tout de suite on évitera
beaucoup de mahler son coup de gueule
est entendu en 2000
martine aubry alors ministre de l'emploi
et de la solidarité propose d'allonger
le délai légal de l'avortement à 12
semaines soit deux semaines de plus
c'est la poursuite d'un mouvement qui
est celui de l'histoire des femmes
l'histoire des femmes c'est le combat
d'abord des associations féminines et
féministes dont nous avons nous profiter
la loi aubry guigou est adoptée le 4
juillet 2001 mais malgré cette avancée
certaines femmes enceintes font encore
face à des contraintes
la plupart du temps on va mettre les
femmes en faute on va leur dire vous
nous contactez trop tard alors que c'est
pas trop tard qu'elle contacte les
hôpitaux c'est que les hôpitaux ne
respecte pas les délais ou c'est que les
hôpitaux nos basses et une médecin pour
faire les avortements en europe
les délais pour pratiquer les ivg
diffèrent selon les pays dix semaines
pour le portugal ou la croatie jusqu'à
24 semaines pour le royaume uni
al'inverse sur l'île de malte liv et
j'ai puni de trois ans d'emprisonnement
[Musique]